Alami: Hello, everybody,
and welcome
to "Secrets and Surprises
of the Google Geo APIs".
My name is Ossama Alami.
I'm a developer advocate
on our Geo Developer
Relations team,
and I'm here today
presenting with Aaron Jacobs,
who is a software engineer
on the Maps API team.
So what do I mean
when I say
"Secrets and Surprises
of the Google Geo APIs"?
Well, what I want to do--
what we want to do in
today's session is give you,
firstly, an overview
of your options as a developer
when you think about
Geo, Spatial,
and Geospatial APIs
at Google,
and then go into some specific
features of the Maps API,
the Earth API, Fusion Tables,
our web services,
and the Static Maps API,
to highlight some features
that you may not know about,
some features
that you may have seen
but don't know how to use,
and give you an idea
of what's new,
and some exciting features.
So we'll start
with the overview.
When you think of Geo at Google,
people typically think of
the Maps API Version 3,
or the Maps API,
the JavaScript
Maps API.
Our JavaScript Maps APIs are now
active on over 600,000 sites,
and it is our primary
mapping API,
and what you typically think of
when you think of Maps at Google
as a developer.
But we have more
than just these,
what I'll call user-facing APIs,
these mapping APIs.
There's the Earth API,
which we'll talk about today.
This lets you embed Google Earth
and a web page
and has a JavaScript API
you can work with.
There's a Maps API for Flash,
for any action script developers
in the audience.
We have a Static Maps API, which
we'll also talk about today.
And then for Android
and IOS devices,
we have a native SDK,
that you can use for mapping
if you're building
a native application.
But there's more than just
these user-facing APIs.
There's a suite of
developer tools,
supporting APIs within
Geospatial at Google,
that support you as a developer
in building these applications.
There's our web services,
Fusion Tables,
both of which we'll talk about,
KML, which is an open standard
for representing
geospatial data,
SketchUp, which is a tool
for 3D modeling,
and you can then
take those models
and put it on Google Earth,
and then Earth and Earth Pro
themselves,
which are client applications
that you can use
to visualize your data
as well as work with
certain data formats.
But there's more to it.
Google has over 100 different
APIs and developer products,
and lots of them that you may
not immediately think of
actually have
a notion of place,
a notion of location or some
geospatial aspect to them.
You can get a user's location
using the Latitude API,
geotag imagery using
Panoramio and Picasa,
or geotag videos
with YouTube API,
updates using the Buzz API,
and then there's some
developer tools,
if you are an organization
or a developer
that has lots of geospatial
data, you know,
satellite images yourself,
you can use Earth Builder
and Earth Enterprise to work
with and visualize that data,
and then tools like
Refine and BigQuery,
that don't necessarily have a
specific geospatial application,
sorry, a specific
geospatial feature--
but they are tools
that you can use to work
with geospatial data sets,
and then query them,
or refine that.
So that's sort of a very quick,
broad overview
of what is available
to you as a developer
when you think of
Geospatial at Google.
And we'll go right now into
some really exciting features
of Maps API Version 3--
again, some features
you may not know about
and some features
that are brand-new.
First, I'll start with
an overview of the Maps API.
We released Maps API Version 3
at last year's I/O, out of labs.
Now if you're--
and we deprecated Version 2.
Now if you have
an active Version 2 site,
I don't want you to worry.
We have a 3-year
deprecation policy.
But I hope some of the things
you see today encourages you
to switch to Version 3,
because that's where
our active development is,
and that's where all of our
new features are built upon.
The advantage of Version 3
is also that it was built
from the ground up to be
both a desktop
and a mobile web-mapping API.
So in addition to support
and the mobile browsers
for Android and Safari, we also
support Blackberry 6 devices,
and the Samsung Bada browser,
and then the standard desktop
browser support as well.
You'll notice IE 6
isn't listed here.
While we--while the maps--
thank you.
While the Maps API will work
in IE 6 and will not break,
there are certain features
that will--
they'll degrade well, but they
won't be available to IE 6.
But you can rest assured that
your map will continue to work
and function with
Internet Explorer 6.
I said "loads of features".
Here are just some of them.
The things in blue
are some of the things
that we're going
to talk about today.
As you can see, there's more to
it than just a map and markers.
You can do so much more
with the Maps API.
And the first thing
I want to talk about
is 45-degree imagery.
So this 45-degree imagery,
you'll notice
I'm looking at an angle,
an oblique angle.
If I zoom out--
this, by the way,
is Google's headquarters
in Mountain View, California,
which is about 40 miles
south of us here--
if I zoom out, I have the
standard satellite imagery.
Now, I have the smooth
transition as a user
when I zoom in to switch
to a 45-degree imagery,
and right now I'm looking north,
which we'll call 40--
which we'll call, sorry,
zero degrees.
I can look east at 90 degrees,
180, 270, and back to zero.
And this is really
high-resolution imagery,
so you can see as I zoom in,
you get a lot--
a lot of detail, more than
what you would get
with just satellite maps.
And as a user, I can turn off
45-degree imagery,
or go back and add labels.
We have an ever-increasing
list of cities
that's available worldwide.
So I was gonna show you
Santa Cruz,
which is just further south
of us here,
and we also have
Venice, Italy,
as well as a large,
ever-increasing amount of cities
available globally.
And so what's the code
look like
to enable this 45-degree
imagery?
It's not enabled by default
for the Maps API,
but it's really, really simple,
and this will be a common theme
in this presentation.
The code to enable
these features
is actually really, really
simple, really easy.
Only a couple lines of code,
and you can have a world
of new possibilities and
features in the Maps API.
So I simply set the map to--
set, on the map,
call "set tilt," pass in "45"
for 45 degrees,
and this enables
45-degree imagery,
so when a user zooms in
at an appropriate zoom level,
it'll naturally switch
to that 45-degree imagery.
And then to reset it,
if I want to disable
satellite imagery,
I just call
"map.set tilt to 0."
And if I want
to programmatically
set the heading,
I just call "map.set heading,"
and pass in one of those--
one of those degrees.
Another feature that is
unrelated to 45-degree imagery,
but I do like to demo
with 45-degree imagery,
because it really gives you
an idea of the surrounding area,
is this overview map control.
So this, I can move the box
either in here,
or as I pan, the overview map
control will update,
and if I go back to map,
it'll switch to map.
This gives me
a higher perspective,
a zoomed out perspective
of where I am looking at,
so the user can really
understand the location,
and this will collapse
or expand.
So the code to this is, again,
very, very simple.
When I create a map,
I pass in "map options."
If I want the overview map
control,
I just pass in
"overview map control true,"
and if I want it open
by default,
I pass in an overview
map control option,
and I say "opened equals true."
A new feature in the Maps API
which I really like
is marker animations.
We have two animations
that we support.
You can see those markers
dropping.
There's the drop animation,
and there's--
as I move this marker, we have
draggable markers as well.
You can see the marker drops
and animates.
This makes it a little bit more
of an interactive experience
for the user, feel like they're
actually performing an action,
and confirmation
that it worked,
because they see
the animation.
And then we also
have the ability
to make all the markers
bounce.
I really urge you to use
this feature with caution,
because a little bit
is fun.
Too much is a little
annoying.
We'll leave
those bouncing.
When I create a marker, if I
want to pass in an animation,
or if I want to animate it,
during creation of the marker,
I just pass in the animation
option here
and I set the animation
that I want.
In this case, "drop."
The other animation we support
is "bounce."
If I've already created a marker
and I want to set an animation,
I just call marker--
on the marker I call
"set animation"
and I pass in the animation
that I want.
And then if I want to clear
the animation,
just call "set null"--
sorry, "set animation,"
"pass," and "null."
So there's been lots and lots
of improvements to markers
in Version 3 of the Maps API
very recently,
including many speed
improvements.
If you want to learn more
about this stuff,
you should go to the session
entitled "Speedy Maps"
which is 10:45 A.M. tomorrow.
Layers is another feature
of the Maps API
that you may not know about.
This enables you to very easily
add additional data
on top of the map.
We support various types
of layers.
The first UM I'm going to demo--
Geo RSS--
let's you consume a Geo RSS file
or a service
and then easily display
that on the map.
In this case, we're hitting
the Flickr API
to get geotagged imagery
of our tech writer's dog
across North America.
And then the other way
that you can get your data
on top of it,
on top of the map very easily
is to use KML.
And in this example,
I'm just loading KML
for transit lines in Chicago.
So the other examples here
are more using Google's data
and showing that
on top of the map.
In this case, I'm showing
traffic in Chicago.
Every time I practice this,
this highway
has always been red,
so I don't know
what's going on there.
And then, bicycling--
this changes the view of the map
and then highlights
bicycling routes,
roads that are known
to be good for biking,
and roads with bike paths.
You can see, as a bicyclist,
I can get a really good idea
of what's easy to bike through
in Chicago.
And then, Panoramio--
I talked about Panoramio
briefly earlier.
Panoramio
is an image-hosting site
that has exclusively
geotagged imagery,
and we've added
a Panoramio layer,
and it's more than just
pulling in imagery.
You can see here,
I get a good idea
of user-contributed images
of Chicago,
but I can also filter
by either a specific user--
so if you have
a Panoramio account
and only want to show
your photos on the map,
that's very easy to do--
or I can filter by a tag.
So here I'll search for
Wrigley, and you see,
the stadium shows up here
and there are various images
that I can pull up.
And then down south,
there's actually a Wrigley
Building in Chicago as well,
and that's coming up.
So all these layers work
pretty similarly.
It's very easy
to instantiate them
for both KML and RSS.
I use the google.maps
KML layer.
It understands both formats,
and I pass in the path
to that file or that service
that's returning either
KML or Geo RSS.
Traffic layer and bike layer
and Panoramio layer,
I just instantiate it.
And then,
for the Panoramio layer,
if I want to filter by user
or by tag,
I just call
"Panoramio layer.set tag"
or ".set user ID"
to filter by those.
And then in all cases,
to add it to the map,
I just call the set map
property of the layer,
and I pass in the map
that I want it to appear on.
If I want to remove it
from the map,
I just call "set map, null."
I talked briefly about KML.
If you want to learn how
to create highly performant KML
for both consumption
in the Google Maps API
and Google Earth,
you should go to the session
titled "High Performance KML
for Maps and Earth"
which is this afternoon
at 3:45.
Draggable directions
is one of my favorite features.
It was a highly requested
feature for the Maps API,
because people saw this
on maps.google.com.
They saw that they could
drag directions,
and now whenever
they see directions,
they want to drag it, right?
The user sometimes
knows a better path
to get to a location.
Here, I'm mapping from Moscone
to our headquarters
in Mountain View, and you know,
maybe I know that 101
is really terrible
this time of day,
and I'd rather take 280.
I can very quickly click
and drag that over,
and it'll update
the textual directions
on the right automatically.
Another feature that
you may not know about is
these text directions actually
link up directly to the map,
so as I click, a user
can see that individual turn.
Draggable directions, again
very easy to add to a map.
This example shows you how to
add directions to a map.
The things I want
to highlight are the top,
these renderer options.
I'm setting draggable to true,
and I'm passing this
into a directions
renderer.
Directions renderer
is the object
that manages rendering
the directions,
both in textual format
and on top of the map.
Now, since the user has
an ability to drag directions,
you as a developer
may want to know
when they've interacted
with that
and when the directions
have changed.
You just need to listen
to directions changed event,
which we now expose.
And then you can perform
some action.
Street View is another
very, very popular feature.
We have a huge Street View
coverage around the globe,
and when we implemented
Version 3 of the Maps API,
we wanted to implement it
in such a way
that it was usable
on all mobile devices.
So we can't rely on Flash
being installed, for example.
So Street View in V3
of the Maps API
is implemented purely in HTML
and JavaScript,
and this gives us the ability
to support you as the developer
adding overlays on top of
the Street View,
so markers and info windows,
as well as completely
custom Street View,
which is a really exciting
feature that I'll demo.
And then, we've also exposed
the Street View service,
the data service,
which lets you query us
to find out where Street View
imagery is available
and some other data about
that Street View imagery.
Here's an example
of overlays.
In this case, these overlays
are just markers.
I have just a cafe,
and a bank,
and here I'm programmatically
going to switch to Street View
using this button.
And you can see,
the marker shows up here,
and so does the info window
on top of the Street View.
Meanwhile, I'm panning,
and everything updates.
As I move down the street,
you can see
there's another marker here
that gets larger
as I get closer.
Naturally, it's a Starbucks.
And that works fine as well.
So this gives you more options
when you're working
with Street View in displaying
data on top of it.
Another feature I'm going
to demo is custom Street View.
Here we have Street View
imagery--
our Google Street View imagery--
outside of our Sydney office.
There's a bunch of buses
parked in front
because it's across the street
from a casino.
As I move down the street,
you can see this is
the standard
Street View imagery.
If I move up the street,
I've added a link,
for this demo,
to the Google Sydney office.
This is not part
of our Street View imagery
that we provide to you,
but something that you can do
as a developer.
And here, I've taken a panoramic
image of the interior
of the Sydney office, the lobby,
and I can view this,
and then, again, link back
out into the street.
It's a great way to do
indoor mapping,
and so that the imagery
for Street View doesn't end
on the street, but rather
takes you into a building.
If you want to learn how to
do this, you should go to
the "Map Your Business
Inside and Out" session,
which is at 1:45 P.M.
tomorrow.
So I said V3,
we optimized it for mobile.
We are also very concerned
about keeping speed up
and latency down.
So when we wanted to add
features to the Maps API,
we didn't want to bulk up
the JavaScript that the user
has to download and then
the browser has to parse,
but we wanted to add some new
and exciting features
and keep the load time down.
So we've introduced this concept
called libraries.
And using a library
is very simple.
When you load the Maps API,
there's just a script tag
to load the Maps API.
I specify a libraries
parameter.
I pass in a comma-separated
list of libraries.
In this example,
you see Panoramio,
which I demoed earlier,
is actually a library
that I loaded for that demo.
And here I have Geometry,
AdSense and Places,
which I'll demo right now.
Geometry is a library
that lets you compute angles,
distances, and areas
from latitudes and longitudes.
So if you want to do
some spherical geometry queries,
you can use it--
load this library and use it.
And it also comes
with an encoding library
that lets you encode a path,
so encode an array
of latitudes and longitudes
into a string representation
of that,
as well as decode that back
into latitudes and longitudes.
AdSense.
I imagine most of you
are familiar with AdSense, yeah?
Okay.
AdSense is a way for you,
as a developer or a publisher,
to monetize your site by placing
relevant ads on your site,
and then there's
a revenue-sharing model.
What we found was that a lot
of web pages have just a map,
or a map is the core component
of it.
That's what the user
is interacting with.
And AdSense only displays
relevant ads
based on the context, the
textual content of your website.
So it wasn't getting
the relevancy
of where the user was looking at
to display relevant ads.
Well, we fixed that
with the AdSense library
for the Maps API Version 3.
This is a library that
you can use to monetize, now,
your mapping application.
And it takes what the user
is looking at
and serves relevant ads
for that.
So if a user is looking
in wine country,
north of us in San Francisco,
they'll likely see ads
about hotels, or winery tours,
or things like that.
So it becomes much more
relevant ads
that a user is likely
to click on.
It's very easy to add this
to your map as well.
All you do is create arbitrary
div for the Ad Sense ad
to live in, pass in the format
of the ad,
which is a standard AdSense
format,
and then if you want the ad
to live on top of the map,
you can pass in a control
position for the ad,
but the ad can also
live off the map
and still be tied to
the context of the map--
your publisher ID, so we know
where to send the checks,
the map that it's tied to,
and then whether
it's visible by default.
And then I just create the ad
unit "new google.maps.adsense,"
add unit, pass in the div
that it's living on,
and the ad unit options
that I just described.
And this is what
it looks like.
This is an example of an ad
showing up on top of the map.
Here you can see,
I'm looking in Monterey,
which is south of us,
another tourist destination,
has a famous golf course nearby,
so I'm seeing ads for hotels
and a golf course.
Oh, man.
Okay.
So you can see,
I'm moving.
This moves to the bottom left.
Let's see if this works.
Sorry about this, guys.
This moves to the right.
Apparently if I use
a drop-down box three times,
it'll fix itself.
[indistinct chatter]
[laughs]
So very, very easy to--
so that sort of shows you
where it can live on the map
and then the format will change,
the actual format of the ad--
I'm not going to click
on that right now--
to either--any of the standard
AdSense formats.
So you know, one
of them is a long bar,
one of them
is a bigger box,
is a smaller box, et cetera.
And then Places--
Places we announced
that we launched
out of developer preview
in the session
earlier today.
There's also a Places library
that you can load
for the Maps API Version 3.
It supports two services:
auto-complete,
which, if you're familiar
with maps.google.com,
when you start typing, you see
a list of possible results,
auto-completion of addresses
or auto-completion of
business locations.
We're giving you the ability
to have that same feature
on your sites,
using the auto-complete
functionality and Places.
And then we have
a Places search service,
which given a bounting box
or a latitude and longitude
and a radius,
will let you search for
local business listings
and points of interest.
If you want to learn more
about how to use Places,
including the web services
we're launching with Places,
you should go to the
"Location-Based Development
Using Google APIs" session,
3:00 P.M. tomorrow.
And so I talked
about libraries,
but what we also make available
are utility libraries.
These aren't loaded through the
libraries tag in the Maps API,
but are instead open-source
utilities that you can download,
modify, and then use
in conjunction with your map.
They are developed
by the Maps API team,
and we do actively develop them
and support them.
You'll find utilities
that do clustering,
that do custom markers
and info windows,
that do root boxing, and then a
very highly requested feature,
Google Earth integration,
we recently released as
an open source library.
So you can download
this library
and get the Earth button
on Maps.
You know, it's Map,
Satellites, Earth,
and it'll transfer all the items
that you have on your map
to the Earth instance
and sync the two.
So a user can now view the map--
view your content
using Earth as well--
which leads me into discussion
about the Earth API.
Again, the Earth API is a way
for you to embed Earth
in a web page, and it has
a JavaScript API around it,
so that you can define
the user experience
and what content
is displayed on top of it.
It does require a browser
plug-in, the Earth plug-in,
which has support on
both Windows and Mac.
And what does this
look like?
There we go.
So here's Google Earth.
I can turn on borders.
There are various options
for what I can do.
I programmatically
set a button
that just jumps to
San Francisco.
I can pan down here
and turn on or off terrain.
One of my favorite features
is the buildings layer.
This gives you
a really good idea
of what a city looks like
in 3D
as opposed to a top-down view
of a map.
Excuse me.
And as this loads,
you'll see more and more detail
will come in,
in San Francisco
and the Bay Bridge.
And then, we recently
added trees to Google Earth.
We have over 80 million
trees mapped.
We get this data from
a variety of sources.
A lot of it is actually
from satellite imagery now,
so it's where we pick up trees
and add the specific type
of tree to that location.
Let's see.
Here we have trees,
and if you don't believe me,
we have also enabled
Street View.
If I click and drag this here,
there are all the trees.
Another thing I'll show you
in Street View--
we'll jump to Moscone here--
is, as opposed to Street View
on Google Maps
and the Maps API,
Street View in Earth
is actually continuous.
It does interpolation of
the imagery, between panoramas,
and so it's a much more
fluid experience
going up and down
the streets.
So that's a very cool feature,
only available in Google Earth.
I must say though, my favorite
feature in Google Earth
is historical imagery.
This gives you access
to Google's historical imagery,
satellite imagery.
Google is a relatively
young company.
We've been around
for about a decade,
and Keyhole, the company
that was acquired,
that then built Google Earth,
is even younger than that,
but we've been actively
acquiring historical imagery
and adding it to Google Earth,
which you can access
through the API.
This enables you to build
really new types of applications
that deal with history
and the context of a place.
Here I'll show you.
I'll enable
historical imagery.
I've got a slider--
which as a developer,
you can show or not show.
And then, I can disable it,
re-enable it,
and I'll jump to
San Francisco in 1988
to show you a cool demo
that I like to show.
So there was an earthquake
in San Francisco in 1989
that collapsed
this freeway here
that led sort of through
the heart of the city.
I'll show you.
This is the city.
So we can actually
see that.
This is prior
to the earthquake,
and if I move the historical
imagery forward to 1993,
you can see
that the earthquake--
or, sorry, the highway
collapsed,
and then
they took down the freeway.
But there's still a freeway
here, and as I move forward,
you can see that they actually
tore down that entire freeway
and built
this ground-level promenade.
And then,
jumping to the current time,
you can see
that they've added trees
and it actually looks
quite pretty.
But what I love to show
about this demo
is that, even 20 years later,
there is a scar
that runs through the city.
Where the freeway used to be
is now all parking lots.
In fact, this is the only new
building that's been developed,
and if I jump back to 2008,
you can see it's a parking lot
as well.
So 20 years later,
after the earthquake,
there is still a visible scar
that you can see
through the city,
that you can now--
you can tell these stories
using our historical imagery
in the Earth API.
And then I want to talk
about Fusion Tables.
Fusion Tables is basically
a tool for storing,
collaborating, and sharing
large amounts of data.
You can think of it
as a cloud-based database,
with tight integration
with the Maps API,
spatial query support,
and a sequel-like
query syntax and API.
The best way to show
you Fusion Tables
is to actually do
a quick demo.
So here I have Fusion Tables.
I have a list of tables
that I own,
and I'm going to show you
two examples.
First is this table of roughly
2,000 Brazilian beaches.
I have the name of the beach,
latitude, and longitude.
One of the most difficult--
one of the most common questions
I get is, you know,
"I have 10,000 points
"that I want to show
on the map.
What's an easy way
to do this?"
Well, creating an individual
marker for those points
gets quite cumbersome
and very slow,
can be very slow
in a browser.
So Fusion Tables supports
a very easy way
to visualize this data.
I can just click
"visualize map," and you see,
it's rendered out
all these 2,000 markers
on top of 256-pixel
square tiles,
which is the same tiling scheme
that the Maps API uses,
so it's a transparent tile
with just the markers,
and then through JavaScript,
it does the hit testing
to determine where a marker is
and then pull that data through.
So this is a very quick map.
There is no lag.
I very quickly added
these 2,000 points.
And then if I want to display
a heat map,
I just click a check box.
Now, it's very easy
to display a heat map.
A heat map is,
in case you don't know,
not a map of temperature.
It is a map of density.
So there is a high density
of beaches located down here,
and it's not quite as dense
with beaches over here.
And then the other demo
I'll show you is this.
So I downloaded a CSV from
the American Community Survey,
which is this government
organization
that puts out demographic data
every year.
So it's broken down by
congressional districts,
and it has some
demographic data,
like what's the median age
of this congressional district.
And then, using Fusion Tables,
I merged this CSV.
I uploaded the CSV
to a fusion table,
and then I merged
that fusion table
with a fusion table of all the
U.S. Congressional districts,
the shapes of the U.S.
congressional districts,
which I found on
Fusion Tables.
We have a set of public tables
that you can download from,
and you can make your data
public as well.
So you can see, you know,
here is a shape of--
or various shapes of the first
Alaskan Congressional district.
Maybe there's only one.
There's only one.
And I can visualize this
on a map,
so it supports
more than just points.
It supports polylines
and polygons.
This is not a particularly
interesting map, because,
you know, I can click on this
and I get all the data,
but it doesn't really tell me
anything.
I can very quickly click
on configure styles.
Let's say I want to color
this map
based on the median age
of the population--
let's say from green to red
and 25-50.
And you see now
I get a thematic map,
a map that I can
very quickly look at
and see which Congressional
districts trend older
and which Congressional
districts trend younger.
And then if you're done,
if this is all you want to show,
I can actually just get
an embeddable link here,
copy and paste into my web page,
and I get a map.
But there's more.
I mentioned tight integration
with Fusion Tables
in the Maps API Version 3.
Well, that's exposed through
another layer
called the Fusion Tables
layer.
You can see
this is a Maps API site,
not an embedded I-frame
from Fusion Tables.
It is in fact styled,
which is a feature Aaron
will talk about in a little bit,
and here I'm displaying
the Brazilian beaches
on top of my Maps API site,
so I can just define
the experience however I want.
And I can enable heat map
through the Maps API.
Maybe I need to click this
two more times.
Yay, that worked.
And so I'm also
going to show you
the Congressional districts maps
that I just made.
And it supports arbitrary
queries, so here,
I'm selecting the shape of
the congressional district
from my table ID,
where the median age
of the total population
is over 30,
but I can very quickly
switch this to 40,
and very quickly
I get dynamic results back,
so you can build really
lots of exciting applications
this way.
Okay.
There we go.
Fusion Tables layer
works like the other layers.
You just create
a new Fusion Tables layer.
In this case,
I pass in a query.
If all I want to show
is my fusion table
without refining or filtering
the query at all,
I can just provide
the table ID.
Otherwise,
the sequel-like syntax,
where you can say average age
is above 40, and then
if I want it to be
a heat map or not,
I just set heat map
to true or false.
If I want to set it,
it's the same as other layers.
Just call "set map,"
or call "set map," "pass,"
and "null" to clear it.
So that's just a tiny bit of
the features of Fusion Tables.
If you want to learn more
about Fusion Tables,
how it integrates
with the Maps API,
and some new features
we're launching,
you should go to the
"Managing and Visualizing
Your Geospatial Data
with Fusion Tables" session,
which is today at 1:15.
With that,
I'll bring up Aaron.
There you go.
Jacobs:
Thanks, Ossama.
Is this on?
Yes.
Thanks, Ossama.
And, hi, everybody.
I'm here to talk about
Maps API web services
and the Static Maps API.
What is the Maps API
web service?
Well, in contrast
to the user-facing APIs
that Ossama discussed--
the JavaScript, Flash,
Static Maps API and so on--
this is a database service
for you to call from your
native code or backend server
and to consume information
in JSON or XML.
It lets you benefit
from Google's expertise
in geospatial data, so you can
do geocoding to find out
where a street address
is on Earth,
in latitude/longitude, and
other information about it.
You can do directions queries
and more,
which I'm going
to talk about here.
I do remember that we have
a terms of service
that requires you to eventually
do something with this data
on a Google map,
through the JavaScript,
Flash, Static Maps API,
Earth API, so the idea here
is you can do further
computation with your server
or your application
and eventually display a map
to a user
doing something intelligent
based on the results
of that computation.
Oh, also, I should mention,
most of the services
I'm going to talk about here
are also available
in the JavaScript API,
so look at the documentation
for that to see that you can
also use it from the client
if that's appropriate
for your app.
So the first one
I'm going to talk about
that you may have missed
is the Elevation API.
Now this is exactly
what it sounds like.
It allows you to give us a line
or a set of points
and to find out the elevation
of those points on earth.
That's both elevation
above sea level
and below sea level
for points that are underwater
in oceans and lakes.
This uses our cool bathymetry
data that we have
that you can see on
Google Earth, previously.
Now you could use this
to visualize elevation profiles
or do intelligent things
for bikers or walkers
and other stuff
that I haven't thought of.
You guys are the creative ones.
It's really easy to use.
For example, here I have sort of
a trivial request that says,
"Given a path from lat. long.
0-0 to 0-10--"
this is from the Atlantic Ocean
to the shore of Africa--
"sample this path three times."
You could use
a much larger number.
This is for my example.
"And tell me the elevations
of the points along that path."
So you get back
a JSON or XML response
that looks something like this.
You see we sampled it at 3.00010
and one in the middle,
and you can see that you go
from approximately
5 kilometers under the ocean
to a little bit shallower,
to about sea level as you hit
the coast of Africa.
It's that easy to use.
Check out the documentation.
It has a couple other
clever features,
like you can specify points
as addresses
if that's helpful for you.
Another service
I'd like to talk about
that we launched last week is
called the Distance Matrix API.
This is where you have a set
of origins and destinations,
and you want to find out for
each pair of origin/destination
how far they are
from each other.
Now, this is in terms of
drive time and drive distance
or walk time and walk distance,
not as the crow flies,
so this can be pretty useful
to you.
It uses our Directions
API data.
So for example, if you want
to find out how far it is
from L.A. to San Diego and--
sorry, from L.A. or San Diego
to San Francisco or Sacramento,
you would make a request
that looks like this--
you see it's very easy--
and get back this information.
Now what's this good for?
You could, for example,
use this to make
an advance store finder app,
which given a set of
your stores or locations
or whatever it is that
you are displaying,
and the user's location,
or a couple of users' locations,
home and work,
you can do intelligent things
based on this,
much smarter than getting the
closest store as the crow flies,
which might involve
a heavily trafficked road
or something like that.
Yes.
Another directions related
service is route optimization.
Now, if you've used
the Directions API,
you know that you can give
an origin and a destination.
Say the user wants to go
from A to D, via B and C,
so that means you need to hit
points B and C in the middle.
Previously, if you tell us this,
we'll just naively follow
the set of points
that you specify,
but this may not be optimum.
What we allow you to do is,
in your way point list,
you can say "optimize true,"
and what we'll do is
we'll reorder those
intermediate way points for you
so that the user,
or whoever's traveling,
has the most efficient route
through all these points.
This is known as the
traveling salesman problem,
for those who are familiar
from computer science.
As with all of the things
I've mentioned so far,
it's very easy to use.
You just say "optimize, true."
We hold the origin
and destination fixed
because we assume that's
where the user wants to start
and wind up,
and we do the magic for you.
We'll give back
the right directions
based on the optimum order,
and if your application
needs to know how they were
reordered for some reason,
we return the field
called "way point order"
that tells you that.
So for example,
with this query here,
I've generated a few maps
using aesthetic Maps API--
or one map actually--
so this is from L.A. to New York
via these intermediate cities.
The red path is what you'll get
if you do it in the naive order,
and you can see
that it crisscrosses
all over the country.
It's very inefficient
and probably takes a few days.
Whereas the green path,
you see it's been reordered
to do this in an efficient way.
So yeah, it's exactly
what it sounds like.
Another directions-related
feature
is bicycling directions.
So previously
in the Directions API,
we only supported
driving and walking,
and you guys are probably
familiar with these
from maps.google.com,
which allows you to get
directions, as you know.
We've added support
for bicycling directions,
and all you do is say
"mode equals bicycling,"
and we'll use what we know
about bike paths and local roads
and that sort of thing
to find routes
that are suitable for biking.
So for example,
here's a trip from--sorry,
from Santa Monica
to Hollywood in L.A.,
and if you're familiar with
L.A., you see this red path,
which is the driving path--
takes a couple of freeways
that you really don't
want to take on a bike.
But the green path takes
bike paths and local roads,
and it's probably
quite a bit more pleasant.
We also of course adjust all
of the drive--sorry, ride times
and that sort of thing
according to biking speed.
Moving on, another announcement
that we're making--
or have made recently,
excuse me--
is that now everybody is allowed
to use SSL for our web services
and JavaScript requests.
If you're not familiar with SSL,
this is a way
to encrypt the data
that the browser
or your code sends to Google
so that nobody in between
can snoop on it.
You can use this if you have
sensitive user application data
that you don't want anybody
in the middle to see.
And it's just kind of
a good idea for the Internet,
for users' data.
Previously this was a feature
that was only available
to Maps API Premier customers,
but now you can all use it.
Everybody can use it.
It's very easy.
All you do is make sure
you're sending your request
to maps.googleapis.com,
and change your URLs
to use HTTPs,
and it's that simple.
You don't need to make
any other changes.
Right, so moving on to
the Static Maps API.
The Static Maps API is an
alternative to the JavaScript
and Flash and Earth APIs,
which are for interactive maps
that are sort of immersive
for the user.
They can drag them around
and zoom in and out
and do what they like.
If you're in an environment
where you don't have JavaScript
or Flash available, or where
latency is absolutely critical,
what the Static Maps API
allows you to do
is create an appropriate URL
that will return a map image
that can contain markers
and polylines
and custom icons,
but is not otherwise
interactive.
And you simply stick
that in an image tag,
and now you have a map on your
site, or in your mobile app,
or whatever environment
you're in.
I should mention,
there is a requirement
that if you're in a mobile app
or anything like that,
you need to link back to
maps.google.com in some manner.
But it's very easy to use.
You simply give a size,
and you can say--for example,
if you want to show
a map of Australia
with these cities
highlighted with markers,
all you do is
make a URL like this.
You get back a map like this.
Isn't that beautiful?
I have a couple Static Maps
API features to discuss.
The first one is
high-resolution static maps.
So for example, if you are
on a mobile device
with a high DPI screen or you
need a map for printing purposes
or anything like that,
what you can do is tell us
to upscale the map
by 2x or 4x.
And what we'll do is
we'll give you a map back
that has twice or four times as
many pixels in each dimension,
and more rendering detail.
So when you show that map
at the same physical size
on the mobile screen or printed,
it will look better.
It will look less fuzzy.
It's pretty easy to use.
You just say "scale equals two,"
"scale equals four."
If you have custom icons
for your markers,
there's a way to specify
that these are
the appropriate resolution, and
we will render them correctly.
So for example, here's a map
of Sydney at our usual scale,
and I will show you one
at 2x scale which--
imagine it has gotten
twice as large
and is now outside
the bounds of the slide.
It's kind of hard to show
on a projector,
but you see that all of
the labels have gotten larger,
the road detail
has gotten larger,
there's more rendering detail
there.
So now if you shrunk this back
down to the same physical size,
it would look better
for your user.
See the documentation for more
explanation of how this works.
Finally, one other feature
is custom static map styles.
Now, this is also available in
the JavaScript and Flash APIs.
But it's this
really nifty feature
that allows you to change the
default styling of Google Maps
to fit the branding
of your application or product,
or to emphasize particular data
by de-emphasizing other data,
or coloring it
or however you like.
It's based on a set
of style parameters
in the Static Maps API,
where you give
a list of features
that you'd like to restyle--
for example, roads or water
or anything like that--
elements
you'd like to restyle,
like their labels
or their geometry or both,
and then
a way to restyle them--
for example,
changing their color
to something
that's bluish here.
Let me give you an example.
This is a map of the area
around the Moscone Center
where we currently are.
You can see
it's in the Google style
that we all know and love,
hopefully.
And if you change it,
you can change it
relatively significantly.
I've re-colored the roads
to be blue,
done some desaturation.
I've turned off some labels,
for example the P and the--
I can't read it from here,
but these labels.
And you see it's all gone.
You've significantly changed
the look and feel of the map.
Now we have a--if you Google
for "styled map wizard,"
we have this nifty tool
that will let you interactively
create these styles.
And you can see
that it's pretty powerful.
So for example,
here's a map of San Francisco.
I can easily change the water
to red, say add style,
and for example, change
the roads to green,
and now I have a map that seems
quite a bit different.
It's also very ugly.
Please be careful with this,
but it's up to you to make
things that look nice
and emphasize what you want
to emphasize.
Excuse me, I need to go
back to my slides.
So in summary,
Geo APIs at Google.
There are a lot of them.
It's not just
the JavaScript Maps API.
We have Flash,
we have Earth,
we have all of
the other products
that have geo-integration
that Ossama mentioned.
The Maps API itself
has a ton of features.
You often just see maps
that are a base map
and markers and that's it.
Go beyond that.
You can make great
user experiences.
Fusion Tables is a powerful
platform for storing your data
and visualizing it
in even more advanced ways.
We have the Earth API
for all these interactive
awesomeness and trees.
And we have secure web services
that you can talk to
from your back end,
make sure user data doesn't go
out from the browser,
optimize for latency,
whatever you need.
And we have the static map.
The Static Maps API,
when JavaScript and Flash
aren't an option,
or you need to optimize
for latency again, as I said.
With that, I'm going to say
thank you.
I'm going to invite Ossama up
for Q&A,
and I'm going to mention,
if you'd like to give us
some feedback on this talk,
please do.
Here's a short link
that you can visit
to give us feedback.
Thank you.
Alami:
Thanks very much.
Jacobs: Does anybody
have any questions?
Alami:
Go ahead at the mic.
man: So a couple
quick questions
in relation to Fusion Tables.
For one, how large
of a fusion table
do you guys support, and like,
could I upload a million points?
Alami: I believe we support
up to 150 megs.
man:
Okay.
Alami: But you can purchase
larger amounts.
man:
Okay.
And then the second question is,
I know they come back as images.
Is there a special on-click
event where I can hook in
and have first priority
on getting the data
of where the point is?
And I'll give you
my specific use case.
Really nice to have
all those as an image
because it's less--
Alami: Right.
man: It's more performant,
there's no DOM elements.
But if I have a user
that hits a mouse down
and clicks
on the actual point,
I'd like to be able to
inflate it
as a regular DOM element.
Is that something
I can hook into
through an event
and get back the dimensions
of the place?
Alami: Yes.
man: Okay.
Alami: So we do expose events
based on clicks,
and you could also query
Fusion Tables API separately,
but we do expose that through
the Fusion Tables layer.
man: Okay, so I just take that
and I can drop it
into a new mount marker,
sort of, its own parameters
and it'll just create one
at that point?
Alami: That's right.
man: Cool.
Alami:
We'll take the front.
man: So last I checked the--
sorry, the Maps API for GWT
is stuck on Version 2.
Is that still the case,
and do you have plans
to update that?
Alami: I don't know
the answer to that.
I know there are--
sorry.
The question was,
the Maps API for GWT
is currently on Version 2.
I know there are a couple
of open-source Version 3
implementations
of the Maps API.
I don't know what the current
plan is for Version 2,
the GWT implementation.
We'll--back mic.
man: I've got two
quick questions.
One is, I saw you color-code
various states on the USA map.
Do you actually ship political
boundaries that we could use,
or do we have to get it
ourselves?
Alami: So the question was,
on the U.S. map
for the Fusion Tables example,
I showed U.S. Congressional
district boundaries.
Where did I get that data?
I actually pulled that data
from Fusion Tables.
We have a large set
of public tables
that we've made available
as well as users
who have contributed data and
made that available publicly.
So in Fusion Tables,
all you have to do--
all I searched for, in fact, was
U.S. Congressional districts,
and it's the first table
I found.
man:
I see, I see.
I have two more
quick questions.
One is, in a typical map,
is there an upper limit
to how many markers
I can display--
like, can I display
20,000 markers?
Alami: Yes, so there
is an upper limit.
The question was--
Jacobs: How many markers
can you show on a map?
We do pretty well these days
with lots of them,
with thousands even,
but if you have, like,
a truly ridiculous number,
you can use something like
Fusion Tables
or a KML layer or two
to offload some of that work
to the server side and save
the browser from doing it,
and it's even more performant.
Alami: Yeah.
Specifically,
there is no hard limit.
You can continue to add
as many markers as you like.
Your browser performance
will suffer.
man: I see.
Alami: Yeah.
man: And the last question is,
say I have a database
that has like 1 million
addresses, customer addresses.
Is there a tool
Google offers
to convert them
into lats and longitude?
Alami: So the question was,
if you have a database
full of addresses,
and you wanted to geocode
all those addresses--
so if you upload them
to Fusion Tables,
Fusion Tables will take care
of the geocoding.
Jacobs: There also
is the opportunity
to use the geocoding
web service,
which is one of those
web services I mentioned.
You do need to make sure
that you're within
the terms of service, using
this with a map eventually.
I'm not sure of the details.
Sorry, I'm not a lawyer.
But you can use either
of these methods.
man: Thank you.
Great presentation.
Jacobs:
Thank you.
man: I had a small question
regarding the Sun Cells input.
Is there anything for,
for example, compass,
gyroscope, or any
accelerational movement?
So basically, in the API,
if the compass moves around,
do you have any simple input
or do you need to use a 0,
90, and 180 and so on?
Alami: So the question
was if there's any tie-in
to sensors on the phone,
for instance, gyroscope.
There isn't anything specific
in the Maps API.
You'd have to code
that yourself.
Jacobs: You can of course
get it from the HTML5,
support for it, or I think
there are other technologies--
I'm not too familiar with this--
but no, we don't have
anything canned for you,
sorry.
man:
Okay. Thanks.
Alami: I will do
the back mic.
man: Yes. Is it possible to
work in offline mode?
No Internet?
Alami: The question was, will
the maps work in offline mode?
The answer is no.
Jacobs: Yeah.
Alami: We load map tiles
from our servers,
as well as if you use
services like geocoding,
or you rely on any of those.
It requires an Internet
connection to make that work.
man: What if we have
Enterprise database?
Alami: It would still require
Internet connection
to make that work.
The one--sorry,
the follow-up question,
I've been told by everybody
to repeat the questions.
The follow-up question was
what if you have
an Enterprise database
or something.
There is a product called
Google Earth Enterprise,
which will let you--
man: That's what
I was talking about.
Alami:
Yeah.
So I actually don't know
the specifics about that,
but if you visit us
in office hours,
or in the sandbox,
I can find somebody
to answer that question
for you.
Jacobs:
Maybe at the front here?
man: Do you have any integration
with Google Latitude?
Alami:
The question was,
are there any integration
options with Google Latitude?
There are no canned
implementations.
There is
no canned integration,
so you would have to write
that on your own.
man:
Okay, great, thank you.
Alami:
Sure.
Jacobs:
In the back?
man: The Fusion Tables--
you mentioned there was
a 150 data point limit
on that.
Is there a way to
layer multiple ones of those?
Jacobs: It's actually
150 megs, I think.
man:
Oh, 150 megs?
Jacobs: So you can put
a lot of data in there.
man: Okay, I've got
more than that easily.
Is there a way that you can
layer multiple layers
on top of each other--
to, let's say,
do a northwest region
or southwest region--
and then put those layers
and generate heat maps
based on that?
Alami: Yeah.
The question was,
can I layer multiple Fusion
Tables layers on top of the map,
and the answer is yes.
man:
Excellent.
Alami: I believe
you can do up to five?
Jacobs: You might need to be
clever about what to do
with the boundaries,
especially if you're
doing heat maps,
but I'll leave that
up to you.
man: Great.
Thank you very much.
man: My question is on metadata
and coverage information.
For example, when you set the
tilt to the 45 degrees, to 45,
what happens if the data
is not available for the area?
And in general, I want to ask
about coverage
information, like,
given the latitude and longitude
of a city,
do we have historical data
the area--for the area?
I wish you can create
like a Google Maps API
database offline, manual UI
base, to give that information.
That would be very valuable.
Alami:
So a couple of questions.
The first was what happens
if you call "set tilt"
on 45-degree imagery
and we don't have
that imagery available.
It'll simply just show
the satellite mode and--
Jacobs: More generally,
do we have information available
about where we have
various types of imagery,
and I don't know the answer.
Alami: You can query for imagery
within the Earth API,
but we do not have
a web service
that you can hit,
or something within the Maps API
that you can query
for historical imagery.
man: Okay.
man: A few questions
on other layers you might have.
Do you have U.S. ZIP codes?
Alami: The question
was on additional layers.
You can just search
Fusion Tables.
I don't know
off the top of my head
what we have loaded in there,
and in fact,
people have made
layers available
that I don't know about,
so simply go to
google.com/Fusion Tables
and search for
whatever you want,
or you can browse
public layers.
man: And so
this is relatively new, and--
Are you expecting a lot
of user-contributed data?
Jacobs:
Please contribute, yes.
Alami:
Yeah.
Fusion Tables--
when did we--
so Fusion Tables came out of lab
several quarters ago.
It is now not only--
man:
Formally part of the API?
Alami:
It is--
Jacobs: It's sort of
an independent product,
but we have a little bit of,
you know, nice integration here
in the Fusion Tables layer
that Ossama described.
man: Okay.
Alami: Yeah.
And we are,
to answer your question,
yes, we are seeing quite a bit
of usage of Fusion Tables
since we launched.
man: Thanks.
Jacobs: Up front.
woman: Do you provide
any documentation
on the heuristic that you use
for the optimization,
for the routing?
Jacobs: No, we don't.
And I personally don't know,
but I could speculate with you
if you grab me later.
woman:
Okay.
man: So we all have
these Android tablets
with beautiful
Vector Google maps.
Are you planning on bringing
that to the browser
and opening the Vector Maps API
to developers
on browser and mobile?
Alami: The question was about
vector maps on the browser,
and the answer is,
we typically don't comment
on our future product plans.
man:
Okay.
Jacobs: Agreed that it would
be sweet though.
man: Right.
Jacobs: Yeah.
man: Hi. The Maps API that
returns the JSON objects--
I've tried that
with Google App Engine,
and I've, like, been immediately
confronted with--
I guess it's like a 403 or
something, you know, forbidden.
I've exceeded my quota.
And I assume it's just because
someone else on that node
exceeded it.
I was wondering if there's
a way to use a key for that.
Jacobs: So yes,
so this is a difficulty
that we run into in shared
hosting environments.
Sorry, the question was,
I'm on App Engine
or something with a shared IP,
and I get lots of quota denials
in the web services,
geocoding or whatever.
This is a problem that we run
into because of shared IPs.
It's hard to tell who's a user,
who's not.
There is of course
Maps API Premier
that you could sign up for
and get a key,
if you have, like,
a big project.
Otherwise, maybe you can try
to do it on the client
where we have a more clever
strategy for telling
who's an independent user,
that sort of thing.
I don't have a good answer
for you right now,
but grab me afterward.
Twenty seconds, if that's
a quick question back there.
man: I'll try to make it quick.
Jacobs: Yeah.
man: So let's say
that I wanted to generate
a heat map off of
private data,
say the last seven days
of sales,
and it's rapidly changing.
I wouldn't want to upload that
into Fusion Tables
before I make the render
request, right?
So how would I integrate
that kind of live feed
for my own private
book of record, basically,
and generate a heat map
on top of this stuff?
Alami: The question was about
generating heat maps
using a live data feed.
Ultimately you do have to upload
this into Fusion Tables.
You can keep the table
private,
so you're not required to make
this data public.
Jacobs: Unfortunately, it's
a relatively computationally
expensive process in general,
so we're reliant on that
at the moment anyway.
man: Right.
If I could do a quick one.
Alami:
Yeah.
man: So one thing that we talked
with some of your guys about--
Alami:
Sorry.
I'm getting a signal
from the back,
but if you do have
a follow-up question,
we'll meet you afterwards.
Jacobs: Grab us outside. Sure.
Alami:
Thank you.
Jacobs:
Thank you. Thanks for coming.